we're here at the Tokyo Game Show 2015
I'm Justin this is Alexis the end of the
first day and Alexa you got to play one
of the games that we heard about at e3
Dragon Quest builders and do I really
didn't see a lot about it so I mean it
looks like Dragon Quest mixed with
Minecraft but what what is the game
exactly so you're kind of right it is
dragon Dragon Quest mixed with Minecraft
but there's also some don't starve like
elements to it
it looks like Minecraft and that it's
very blocky and you sort of have your
your area here are your rocks and your
wood and your mountains and all of them
are little blocks there they're little
little cubes that you have seen in
Minecraft and you can destroy them to
collect them and then use them later to
build things and you can also go around
and destroy trees and destroy flowers
and destroy isn't like so in Dragon
Quest your main weapon is this little
like baton this little sick and you're
good things with your stick and if you
hit a bird with your stick and get
feathers if you get a flower with your
stick you get gold powder and you can
take all these materials back to your
little crafting table and you can craft
gold you can craft medicine you can
craft stronger materials and you can
take those and you can build houses now
there's two ways to build houses you can
either build them freeform so build them
however you want and then you have to
put in a torch I think it's a torch and
a bed and that makes it a room and you
can upgrade rooms by adding more items
or you can take blueprints there are a
couple blueprints in the game because
Square Enix thinks that some players
maybe want just that RPG element the
dragon quest element and they don't
really want to sit there and figure out
how to build things so they have some
blueprints for houses and it shows you
you know where the door goes and where
the bed goes and where the torch goes
and it sets it all up for you
so that's really neat I did it both ways
and I actually really liked the freeform
so you because you can build like
interesting structures and put like a
bunch of torches in it and a bunch of
beds and make a little house it wouldn't
be a dragon quest game of course without
some RPG elements it yeah how does that
play into a do kala-azar combat do you
have stats that go up er so there's a
little bit of combat there are enemies
floating around in the wild much like in
Minecraft and don't start I would
actually compare this more closely to
don't starve because you have the random
creatures sort of hanging out and until
you get close to it it won't interact
with you so there were these weird
vulture creatures and I collected
from them there were slimes there were
many slimes at one point at one point I
crested a hill and there was just this
field of slimes and they didn't they're
not bad but I killed them anyway because
I wanted there's lime juice and I took
that home and made some crap with it but
that's so that's like don't starve but
you do quests given to you by NPCs so
that's sort of the RPG element you'll
run into people and I say oh I need a
house and need you to build me a house
the bed I'm tired
make me a house so you make them a house
and you can upgrade their house for them
you can also explore I went into the
depths of a mountain I climbed a
mountain and then went into it and found
a treasure chests with some stuff in it
so you can also explore so there's sort
of those two RPG like elements and it
all of course it all looks like Dragon
Quest your character looks like Dragon
Quest and the slimes are there and you
have your stick so it's definitely a
Dragon Quest again guess the music is
also then that seemed fanfare that we
know and love yes the music is very
similar to that of Dragon Quest
unfortunately we can't share it because
of copyright it sounds really exciting
and I don't think we'll get to try it
out this year but probably next year's
when the game is gonna be coming out to
the west and people will get that dose
of Dragon place we don't get a lot of
Dragon Quest games here in particular
bring more dragon capacity I really hope
that so this games coming out of Japan
in January I really hope that people
watch this video and people play the
game and more people play this game so
we can get more Dragon Quest to the west
and I think if Square Enix brings Dragon
Quest builders to the West you'll see
the interest there and maybe we'll be
persuaded to localize some more titles
for those of us that don't speak
Japanese so yeah not a lot of Dragon
Quest games of course come to the west
but if one was gonna make it it would be
one based on the Minecraft franchise and
hopefully we'll get to see this one
coming to the west sometime next year